it's nothing to spend jail we can't  leave that boy out there like that can  you please come in here and help me set  the table if you can't get them to shut  up we are gonna have an all-out brawl  [Music]  come on it's not that bad  you know don't the end of the world like  Oh God  I'm gonna call social services on me no  you just heard on CBS News 4 officers  charges the Rodney King incident found  not guilty for taking these to the  streets so you in no she's not  someone's gotta take the black best  they've been doing any situation still  what you want to do things and never be  the same  [Music]  come  I don't want to outside  baby where is everybody else now look at  me  [Music]  urging everyone is stealth speech  [Music]  you